hey today we'll talk about uncompetitive
inhibition it's important type of
reversible inhibition and let's look at
it in normal circumstances what happens
is enzyme interacts with the substrate
and form a transient enzyme substrate
complex which ultimately give rise to
the product and the enzyme is unaltered
but under the situation of uncompetitive
inhibition the enzyme and substrate
reacts with each other and thus forming
the enzyme substrate complex but
eventually the inhibitor or the
uncompetitive inhibitor binds to the
enzyme substrate complex instead of
binding to the enzyme alone it binds to
the enzyme substrate complex as a result
the enzymatic reaction does not proceed
further and the reaction stops so it
does not give rise to the product
formation now let's look at the whole
situation what we talked about in a
pictorial format in an acquaint equation
format right so here is our basic
equation where one side we should get
product by the conversion of enzyme
substrate complex but as in this
particular situation the uncompetitive
inhibitor is binding so we are getting a
enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
instead of getting a product and the
reaction is not proceeding further and
we have defined all the rest rate
constant for all these reactions and for
these inhibitor binding let be the let
the rate constant be K I now
let's look at the michaelis-menten
equation under this situation and try to
understand what has changed with the
presence of this inhibitor so this is
how our normal Michaelis Menten equation
look like in a V versus s plot and this
is how the equation look like in
presence of an uncompetitive inhibitor
by just looking at this red line which
is the equation in present of in
presence of a uncompetitive inhibitor
you can say that the v-max has decreased
right and the new v-max is way lesser
than the previous V Max also if you look
at the game the game has also decreased
right now the equation which is normal
the michael mentalist equation looks
somewhat like this which is V 0 equal to
v-max into substrate divided by km plus
substrate concentration right but in
presence of an uncompetitive inhibitor
you additionally bring in a term which
is alpha dash now what is this alpha
dash and where it is coming from so in
order to understand that let's try to
derive the equation ok here is our
reaction format again now from this
reaction format if we consider the
inhibitor binding kinetics with the
enzyme substrate complex we can define
our ki - equal to es into inhibitor
concentration divided by the
concentration of enzyme substrate and
inhibitor complex now this is an
important part which we would be used to
derive our equation now at any given
time we know that the total enzyme
concentration is a combination of enzyme
free enzyme plus enzyme in format of an
enzyme substrate complex or the enzyme
in format of an enzyme substrate
inhibitor complex so three kind of
possibilities are there when we talk
about the total enzyme right
now taking es common from this thing we
get to AP's
equation like this now multiplying both
sides would k2 gives us something
interesting previously from Micah's
Michaelis Menten equation derivation we
know that V 0 equal to k2 into es and V
Max is equal to ke to ET and let us
define this 1 plus inhibitor
concentration by ki as a parameter half
a dash now if we plug in all these
values and assumptions what we get is
something like this which would
ultimately leads us to this equation now
we understand what is alpha now alpha is
basically a constant here right now here
you might be wondering that how the red
Khan how the km of the reaction is
decreased so we know that here the
product formation is not happening
most of the es is getting converted to
enzyme substrate and inhibitor complex
as a result the concentration of es is
decreasing but according to L'Arche it
earlier principal what happens is the
equilibrium for this reaction is shifted
right words and more and more es is
formed and if we look at this phenomena
kinetically what is what appears to us
is the affinity of these enzyme towards
the substrate has increase in presence
of this inhibitor now the increase in
enzyme substrate generally indicate the
enzyme has a higher degree of affinity
towards this substrate now let's look at
the kinetic data in a better fashion in
a lineweaver-burk plot in a linear
format so without any inhibitor present
the graph somewhat looks like this and
this is the equation where we have plot
this thing in in an axis of 1 by V by 1
by s
and the slope here is game by v-max and
the intercept is 1 by V Max right now
what we can plot is the equation in
presence of an inhibitor in an
uncompetitive inhibitor and the equation
somewhat looks like this now what has
change is the intercepts not the slope
the slope is the same the intercept has
changed so that's a characteristic of
the uncompetitive inhibition the slope
didn't change for lineweaver-burk plot
whereas the intercept has changed and
depending upon the values of alpha the
equations would shift left 2 left words
and greater de alpha the the plot would
shift left words now here what is
interesting to know is that all these
plots are parallel to each other and
this is a characteristic of
uncompetitive inhibition now in case of
uncompetitive inhibition the enzyme
substrate binds to a region the enzyme
in ingress of uncompetitive inhibition
the inhibitor binds to a region other
than the active site which is very
different from a comparative innovation
in case of competitive inhibition the
inhibitor binds to the active site
actually the inhibitor and substrate
competes for the active site so that is
completely different in case of
uncompetitive inhibition where inhibitor
binds to a site other than the active
site and leads to a conformational
change in the enzyme such that the
enzyme and substrate complex cannot get
converted to an product situation now
let's look at these equation or let's
look at how the substrate containing
substrate concentration this inhibition
is changing so first consider the
equation of uncompetitive inhibition
in this situation let us have a hell lot
of substrate now in case of competitive
inhibition by increasing the substrate
con concentration we can reverse the we
can reverse the inhibition right let's
see what happens here
now if we have too much substrate
substrate concentration then K M becomes
negligible and as a result the equation
becomes somewhat like this then our v-0
or our enzyme reaction have a velocity
which is V max by half a dash and now we
can understand why our v-max or or the
enzymatic velocity is different or
decreased in this uncompetitive
inhibition reaction now let's just
assume that substrate concentration is
way way lesser than the came in that
situation the substrate concentration is
negligible so v-0 becomes v-max s by km
so in case of this kind of uncompetitive
inhibition having lower substrate
concentration is beneficial and can
reverse the effect of this inhibition
now let us take an example of this kind
of enzymatic inhibition reaction so
placental derived alkaline phosphatase
is uncompetitive li inhibited by
phenylalanine so this is an example of
uncompetitive inhibition so that was
pretty much it
about the uncompetitive inhibition so we
discussed the kinetics of it how the
Michaelis Menten equation looks like
under this situation and also we try to
understand the kinetic data using
lineweaver-burk plot I hope you enjoyed
this video if you liked this video give
a thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you